значить брехун - це ви ви брешете
постійно зранку до ночі я це бачу тому
що в травні місяці ви мені не підписали
відрядження на конференцію паре в травні
місяці ви мені не підписали відрядження
спостерігати вибори в Туреччині від
парламентської асамблеї Ради Європи Ну
це неважлива напевно країна в кінці
вересня ви мені не підписали відрядження
в місто Дублін де відбувалось засідання
президентського комітету пар де я б мав
представляти європе
консерваторів ви не підписали ви брешете
зараз і ви змагаєтесь з даніловим Хто в
вас більше язикатий Данілов говорить що
ми значить Туристи в полосатих
купальниках я хочу сказати вам що ми ще
Побачимо хто буде в полосатих робах
ходити Коли все це закінчиться а
відповідати за все це доведеться я вам
це обіцяю і і от розкидуватись словами Я
сидів тут знаєте що спокійно брехун ви
брехун Олексій олексі Y